[musique]
Ce que je considère comme nécessaire est, en fait, un phénomène artificiel.
Affrontez-le de front et obtenez la meilleure forme le plus rapidement possible
Tout d’abord, il est important de discuter
La raison en est que la suppression des écoles primaires est très
C'est un sujet sérieux, alors discutons-en autour de la table.
Il a fallu environ 10 ans entre la publication et la réalisation.
On dit que cela prendra du temps.
Euh, 10, agissez d’ici 10 ans.
Si vous voulez vous réveiller, discutons tout de suite.
devrait commencer
[musique]
est
L'anime est très populaire au Japon,
Séance photo pour les joueurs cosplayers
Ou demandez à quelqu'un de l'utiliser.
Je me demande ce que c'est, euh, dans la formation en entreprise.
Je l'ai utilisé, fait utiliser et filmé.
De diverses manières, par exemple en faisant en sorte que les gens l'utilisent.
Eh bien, promouvons l'existence de cette école.
Créer un formulaire pouvant être utilisé par plusieurs personnes
Vivant
[musique]
Les installations commerciales et commerciales seront construites en utilisant le même type de stationnement.
C'est le café du département des Marches.
Restaurant au coin 2 et ancienne école
C'est
Profitez de l'apprentissage de l'histoire d'Etto-sama
Nous avons également fait le tour de l'îlot de l'usine.
Même le Japon peut le faire.
Un établissement où s'intéresser à l'agriculture
Il n'y a pas, non, non, c'est bien.
Je pense que c'est une initiative de fermer cette école.
Une usine comme celle-ci sera construite en utilisant
Que signifie créer un équipement touristique ?
Je pense que ce sera bon pour la région, c'est donc très important.
Je pense que c'est une bonne initiative pour
[musique]
Masu